this is what it would look like if  Disney Princesses had realistic hair all  that sea spray would have turned Ariel's  natural beach waves into a tangled mess  Bell had more important things to worry  about like taming the Beast  not her unruly bangs Mulan was bound to  have some static flyaways after keeping  her hair in a topknot  all day the colors of the wind would  have blown Pocahontas blowout into a  massive mess all that snow would have  made it impossible for Elsa to visit a  salon and get her icy blonde roots  touched up let him grow let him grow and  princess Jasmine's voluminous pony would  have formed blood for carpet after that  magic ride Snow White's quaffed bob  would have been a frizzy mess of all  that forest humidity and Cinderella  would have woken up from her crazy night  out at the ball with major bedhead  luckily her fairy godmother doubles as  her hair stylist  [Music]